bonjour tout le monde aujourd'hui tout
le québec doit se mettre en mode
d'urgence 12 mars le premier ministre
françois legault tient le premier d'une
série de points de presse qui seront
suivis religieusement pour le mans main
la pandémie de corne au virus et ce
contrôle
au québec le gouvernement ne traîne pas
en moins de deux semaines tous les
commerces et entreprises non essentiels
sont fermés on mêle québec sur pause
dans les hôpitaux on se prépare au pire
ça fait des semaines qu'on se prépare le
personnel a des consignes claires
leur modèle que l'on veut éviter c'est
le modèle italien où le réseau de la
santé a les yeux rivés sur l'italie où
on risque de manquer deux ventilateurs
je me réveille en sursaut toutes les
nuits avec des images d'horreur qui
ressemblait à ce qu est ce qu on
commence à avoir pu lui fallut exorciser
saut le docteur patrick bellemare et
chef des soins intensifs du sus du nord
de l'île de montréal
il pratique à l'hôpital du sacré coeur
le déclic a été rapide pour que tout le
monde se met en mode on s'adapte on
réinvente nos façons de faire on
fabrique lâcheur capacités dont on a
besoin pour pour produire le scénario
italien le docteur bellemare a lui même
filmé les nouvelles installations dans
son hôpital
chez nous il y avait cinq chambres en
pression négative
on a transformé 100 à 130 sur l'espace
de quelques jours
ce scénario se reproduit dans plusieurs
hôpitaux
en quelques semaines le québec double
quasiment sa capacité d'accueil en soins
intensifs
et pendant ce temps là on a libérés en
l'espace de trois semaines cette mini
c'est du jamais vu au québec la pièce
maîtresse de la préparation du réseau ça
a été de vider les hôpitaux on a reporté
les chirurgies non urgentes et tenter de
relocaliser 1400 patients qui n'avaient
plus besoin de soins actifs
on a demandé aussi à celle d'edel mais
beaucoup de patients pour vider les ex
tôt pour faire de la place pour les
patients qui sera hospitalisé le
gériatre davet lussier a été un des
premiers à sonner l'alarmé de farès non
non c'est après l'armée les races
étaient de ne pas préparer les csld
d'impayés parce qu'on se réveille
prépaiement nos vies de jeunes bideau
l'infirmière sylvie morin était au front
dès le début on l'aura unités président
plus d'un sous sol
c'est un flop total au niveau de
prévention des infections la salle en a
convenu qu'un mec 71-71 résidents de
plus sans personnel supplémentaire
il est pourtant les cui clairement dans
ce guide préparé au début de mars par le
ministère de la santé qu'il fallait
prévoir le personnel pour les places
supplémentaires
vous savez des fois entre les deux
qu'est ce qui est possible de face sur
le terrain si vous ne l'avez pas le
personnel fait quoi marguerite blais
ministre responsable des aînés et des ch
et celle des a été confronté à son
impuissance du personnel tu rentrais pas
non plus lui pour savoir là on peut pas
aller chercher les gens la maison l'eau
c'est cette approche simple que cela
beaucoup d'employés se sont absentés
parce qu'ils s'estiment est mal protégé
[Musique]
on n'était pas prêt en termes de
matériel on n'était pas prêts en termes
de personnel on n'était pas prêts en
termes d'organisation des lieux fusée
pour valérie gilbert la vague a frappé
le 28 mars
c'est comme une traînée commencé durant
si on savait pas où donner de la tête
les passants ce matin en page de pub et
toute la procédure derrière le dépistage
est une méthode particulière avez vous
demandé moi données transférées du
matériel des hôpitaux vers le ch à celle
des faut protéger le personnel à ses
achats c'est le voit on le fait je vous
dis la vérité
pour certains équipements on en or pour
trois à sept jours
donc quand même serré pendant des
semaines cruciales les directives sur le
port des équipements de protection ont
été émises en fonction de la pénurie
qu'on avait eu comme information c'est
qu'on n'était pas ce qu'il y avait pas
convaincu ceux qui ont pu les garder les
masques pour le 27 mars
la publication d'une étude américaine à
l'effet d'un électrochoc
on a découvert que dans un établissement
de soins de longue durée de l'état de
washington au moins 50 % des résidents
infectés et potentiellement contagieux
n'avait aucun symptôme
ce matin là j'ai écrit à notre ministre
que la contamination par des personnes
asymptomatiques était confirmée et quand
soins de longue durée
tout le monde devait porter un masque
immédiatement pour le gériatre samir
cina qui pendant la crise était
conseiller du ministre ontarien
responsable des soins de longue durée
il était urgent d'agir à la fin mars
on a réalisé que lakovic 19 c'était du
jamais vu que ça exigeait des actions
différentes pistes la
colombie-britannique modifie entièrement
sa stratégie mais pas le québec et
l'ontario 27 mars lors des claques la
claque avec la transmission
symptomatique
il ya peu une directive cette journée
lundi à partir de maintenant et aux
personnes qui rentrent au ch et celle
des 100 masques commun explique ça je
pense que c'est le plus rapide que mes
jambes avant le docteur richard massé a
été embauché à la fin mars pour prêter
main forte au docteur horacio arruda
il fallait s'assurer qu'on avait les
équipements protection pour tout le
monde la directive de porter un masque
en tout temps auprès des résidents des
ch et celle des arrive une semaine plus
tard mais le mal est déjà fait 284 se
cherche à céder pour lequel il ya eu un
coefficient 114 résidence pour personnes
âgées 59 et ri rtf le 31 mars
on apprend qu'au total 410 milieu de vie
pour aînés sont infectés étrangement le
trio du point de presse ne semble pas
alarmés par la situation
ce qui n'est pas le cas d'un jeune jerry
âtre du chemin
ça voulait dire pour moi au moins deux
trois quatre cinq six fois plus de
personnes puis ça ça voulait dire que
les choses allaient être assidu celles
dans les semaines à venir
on parle beaucoup depuis le début le
docteur quoi que des nouilles n utilise
les médias pour passer un message au
gouvernement
je me demande à la mi mars le ministère
de la santé a créé onze comités
d'experts pour l'aider à gérer la crise
soins intensifs cancérologie chirurgie
dépistage imagerie urgence tout y est
sauf les années comment ça se fait qu'il
y avait pas un comité sur les nerfs y en
avait pas bah y'en a eu un après mais
comment se fait qu'ils n'avaient pas un
an le fait après les aînés sorte de
l'angle mort le 10 avril
on crée enfin un comité année réd d'un
mois après avoir créé les autres comités
nous pourrons compter sur l'expertisé du
docteur quoi de nous y sommes il y avait
déjà 400 foyers d'infection dans les
milieux de vie pour un nez comment ça se
fait qu'on n'a pas créé de comité sur
les années culte et à votre avis je peux
pas vous donner une réponse de la vie
vous suggérer au mois de mars
je peux pas vous donner de réponse
statut jeudi benoît robin
j'ai pas de bonne réponse à plusieurs
reprises durant notre entrevue la
ministre blais aura du mal à expliquer
certaines lenteurs de son gouvernement
quant au docteur arruda et à l'ex
ministre de la santé daniel mais cannes
ils ont tous les deux refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue
[Musique]
le problème est vraiment dans quelques
chsct on a 6 ch et celle des là où on a
la majorité des décès 9 avril
le premier ministre pense qu'il a la
situation bien en main il ne se doute
pas que la pire histoire de la crise est
sur le point d'éclater
on a appris à 20 heures hier soir qui
aurait eu 31 décès à la résidence privée
31 décès mais surtout des résidents
retrouvé baignant dans leurs excréments
sans soins déshydratés et affamés
faute de personnel s'est passé vraiment
là ce qu'on appelle en anglais un game
djendel la saleté com waouh c'est grave
on y le 11 avril il y à déjà plus de 400
morts dans les ch et celle des et c'est
là qu'on prend conscience du drame qui
se joue pourtant les marchés eux au
niveau des ministres il leur a su
seulement le 11 ou le 12 arrive quelque
chose qui est normal est ce que vous
vous avez essayé de les réveiller tout
le monde était réveillée mais tous ne
connaissais pas ce virus l'on savait pas
que ce virus là était aussi aussi
imprévisible en tant que ministre des
aînés marguerite blais est responsable
de 6h et c'est l'idée je disais mon
point de vue bon peut-être que mon point
de vue peut-être que ce que je disais
était pris en considération une semaine
ou deux après c'est important d'agir
vite en temps de pandémie
je pense qu'on rétrospective les gens
vont dire waouh
on a juste retardé d'une semaine pour
faire ceci ou implémenter cela le
docteur samir sina est l'auteur d'une
étude sur l'impact de l'aco vide dans
les établissements de soins de longue
durée au canada t.ry les jours et
semaines d'indécision ou d'inaction vont
se traduire en douzaine en centaines
voire en milliers de dessins
beaucoup de choses ont été faites trop
tard en ch et celle des et ce dès le
retour de la semaine de relâche
on a vu des familles revenir de voyages
qui présentaient des symptômes
la docteure andrée anne parent a perçu
le danger
très tôt on ne demande rien nos
supérieurs de fermer les unités une
histoire bien avant que le premier
ministre ne demande cela les visites en
ch et celle des sont interdites le 14
mars
huit jours après la fin de la semaine de
relâche et c'est comme si on était
toujours eu le même problème avec les
travailleurs des chs ld qui reviennent
de voyage on a vu des semences personnel
qui le 12 mars
on demande aux travailleurs qui
reviennent de voyage de s'isoler mais la
mesure n'est pas rétroactive
alors que la semaine de relâche c'est
terminé six jours plus tôt le lendemain
de cette annonce
la directrice de la santé publique de
montréal dr mylène drouin est cuite au
docteur arruda
je crois que ce doit être rétrospectif
car nous avons maintenant plusieurs cas
de personnel revenus de la relâche qui
développent des symptômes
le docteur arruda répond qu'il est
d'accord mais au sein du ministère
on lui conseille de reculer ce soit d'un
point de vue de ressources humaines ont
exprimé une préoccupation de dire on
cependant dans quoi on s'embarque le
sous ministre associé responsable de la
main d'oeuvre du réseau de la santé
craint de ne pas être en mesure
d'assurer les services essentiels
en fait c'est qu'on savait pas combien
de personnes seraient concernées
qu'est-ce que ça concernait dix mille de
nos travailleurs 20 minutes de nos
travailleurs on a près de 300000
personnes qui paraît dans le réseau en
plus de travailler avec des symptômes
les employés se promènent
ch et celle des à l'autre la mobilité du
personnel dès le 27 mars
la médecin hygiéniste en chef de la
colombie britannique interdit la
mobilité du personnel
la colombie britannique a simplement dit
toi tu restes dans ce centre là toi dans
celui là vous faites tous les deux du
temps plein avec bénéfices c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont stabilisé le système
britannique a dit c'est interdit ils
l'ont fait pourquoi on n'a pas fait un
lieu interdit madame beckham n'ont alors
interdit à le dit dans la mesure du
possible éviter les déplacements le 3
avril dans ses directives ministérielles
mais alors interdite on le fait mais on
n'a pas été capable de le réussir autant
qu'en colombie-britannique parce qu'on
n'avait pas assez de personnel
si on avait été vers une interdiction
totale et radicale notre analyse à ce
moment là et à dire qu'on aurait pu
causer des préjudices importants
on pense que mathématiquement c'était
cette époque possible de de travailler
là dessus il a été impossible d'obtenir
des chiffres permettant de comparer les
pénuries de main d'oeuvre en
colombie-britannique et au québec mais
il est établi
que la colombie britannique avait elle
aussi un niveau critique de postes
vacants l'autre pénurie qui a fait mal
et celle des tests de dépistage
ces dépistages ont été très très long à
obtenir pour nos patients chcl 2 on
savait que les gens qui avaient trouvé
la maladie ou tout début étaient des
gens qui revenait de voyage dont la
concentrer nos éléments l'action
les premiers qu'on les avait sûrement
depuis quelques jours même conviction au
ch et celle des scènes dorothée je
démarre son décès c'est chalon de vue
les tester mon achat la recommandation
de tester les résidents des sièges et
celle des qui présentent des symptômes
n'arrive pas avant la dernière semaine
de mars
la masse des terrains comme à la porte
de l isolement
on n'était pas les gens musulmans non on
s'habillait réponse de la part de chacun
en six semaines entre la mi mars et la
fin avril il y a eu 2000 décès en chsct
on devait avoir des décès par jour juste
notre étage
il descendait les gens la savourer le
succès des bills d'engins monsieur lui
et à côté de ce passé qui était décédée
depuis on le sait qu'au jeu quasiment 24
heures au pire de la crise il y aura
près de 100 décès par jour en ch et
celle des et des milliers d'employés
absent dans des unités on était vraiment
dans une majorité de postes où il y
avait les personnes étaient absentes
vraiment donc d absentéisme de plus de
60 70 pour ça je devais que c'était le
chaos total
audry est infirmière elle a été envoyée
en renfort au ch et celle des scènes
dorothée au début d'avril c'est la
coordonnatrice qui m'a accueilli puis
elle me dit me changer dans une salle de
bain puis hamadi directement une unité
et le complète je paye aucune formation
malheur cette infirmière qui désirent
préserver son anonymat par crainte de
représailles de son employeur a été muté
au ch et celle des la pinière de laval
le manque de personnel était tellement
grand que effectivement les gens sont
arrivés et puis même en entrant dans le
bâtiment le celi les premiers jours
c'était c'était plus ou moins organisés
dans un monde idéal on aurait dû
peut-être d'avoir plus grande
planification de soi devrait faire pas
mal tous les corps de travail
j'avais l'impression d'avoir perdu le
contrôle j j pl est sculpté encore
aujourd'hui à vivre avec ce que j'ai vu
l'émeute a fait plusieurs fois de plus
elles sont encore de travail puis nous
voulons tout abandonner mais c'était
juste un costume à fond pendant des
semaines des infirmières formées pour
sauver des vies vont assister
impuissante à une hécatombe pour
laquelle personne ne les a préparés
[Musique]
dans la suite de notre enquête on vous
raconte l'histoire d'une médecin qui a
fait une découverte qui aurait pu sauver
des vies mais qui ont frappé un mur à la
santé publique
[Musique]
on dit qu'en temps de crise
l'information c'est le nerf de la guerre
et c'est encore plus vrai en temps de
pandémie
où sont les malades les morts qui est
atteint comment ont-ils été contaminés
vous allez voir dans ce qui suit que les
données ont cruellement fait défaut
au début d'avril
le ch est celle des la flèche de
shawinigan est en éclosion majeur de
colis de 19
le premier usager qui est infecté
c'était le 23 mars puis deux semaines
après j'ai su qu'il y avait 40 usagers
qui était un fait docteur les andré
galarneau est responsable de la
prévention des infections dans les
hôpitaux de la mauricie mais pendant la
crise elle a décidé d'intervenir en ch
et celle des jeunes landais que tout les
juges ajoutent les résultats soient
dépistés puis on a trouvé 40 nouveaux
usagers infectés de plus
au total près de 80 usagers soit la
moitié des résidants du csld sont
infectés c'est là que je me suis dit
quel quoi qui se passe qui est pas
normal docteur galarneau demande un
dépistage de tous les travailleurs du ch
sld et découvre que 65 d'entre eux ont
la coved
elle se rend dans les bureaux de la
direction régionale de santé publique
pour avoir les données qui lui
permettront de comprendre ce qui se
passe mais elle se fait montrer la porte
écoutez c'est à des données de la santé
publique puis pour eux c'est des données
qui sont privés qui leur appartiennent
donc je n'ai heureusement je n'y ai pas
eu accès
docteur galarneau perd un temps précieux
mais réussit tout de même à découvrir
une information cruciale neuf
travailleurs auraient été contaminées
avant même qu'un premier résident le
soin j'ai compris que leur rôle de
l'usagé était marginal dans la
contamination des travailleurs de la
santé le gros des travailleurs de la
santé se contaminaient entre eux
on est à la mi avril déjà près de 600
résidents sont morts dans les chs ld et
on vient de découvrir que les
travailleurs ne se protège pas
adéquatement les uns des autres
la santé publique avait ces données là
comment ce fait qui réagissait pas à
cette année là il les avait mais je ne
crois pas qu'ils les avaient analysé la
direction de la santé publique de
mauricie a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue mais dans un courriel
elle indique avoir analysé les données
rapidement
je pense que d'abord le portrait réel
amp le portrait réel et en temps réel et
mise à jour de la situation de chacun
des sièges celle des a été assez
difficile au départ
[Musique]
les données sont difficiles à obtenir
même pour l'expert nommé par le
ministère pour le conseiller
je cognais à toutes sortes de portes
pour les avoirs qu'ils avaient toutes
sortes de barrières
peut-être qu'elles sont pas si
disponible que ça et 2,6 que le québec a
dit loi d'accès à l'information très
très sévère qui sont bonnes mais dans
une façon de temps des ministres ce plus
difficile
en plus d'être difficile d'accès les
données sont souvent un retard sur la
réalité
les données étaient dans des systèmes
d'information qui était volée qualifié
de l'étude est souvent l'information
était transmise sûr débit d'eau des
feuilles manuel et puis transmise par
fax
le 15 avril le docteur arruda pense
qu'il y ait environ 250 décès dans les
ch et celle des les statistiques
compilées depuis montre qu'il y en avait
plus tôt c'est sans presque trois fois
plus c'est compliqué la déclaration des
déchets parce que les gens peuvent dire
il est décédé mais ce qui est décédé de
covin surtout notre eau le temps d'avoir
cette confirmation lors on peut être
longue dans certains cas qu'est ce que
ça aurait changé très concrètement
d'avoir les données à jo on aurait su
faire la partition entre 6h et celle des
peuples est en général plus rapidement
et je pense qu'on aurait réagi de façon
adéquate en priorisant davantage et
c'est à chasser des essarts et fait
toute la différence au monde parfois
même avec les données en main il était
difficile de faire bouger les choses
après avoir découvert comment les
employés répandait le virus en ch à
celle des docteurs galarneau a élaboré
un plan d'action incluant de la
formation et nos stratégies de dépistage
aux cinq jours aux stocks on l'a
appliqué la semaine suivante on avait eu
un contrôle complet de l'éclosion malgré
un succès spectaculaire au ch et celle
des la flèche la santé publique refusent
d'appliquer la stratégie de dépistage du
docteur galarneau avant que 150 nouveaux
travailleurs et résidents soit infecté
dans deux autres ch et ses idées c'est
une aberration ce qui est arrivé au
québec et en ontario
ce sont les provinces où on aurait dû
avoir la meilleure expertise notre
capacité de réagir dans les ch et celle
des dans ces deux provinces a été bien
en deçà de ce qu'elle aurait dû être
[Musique]
entre le 23 mars et le 23 juin
la coved emporté près de 4000 personnes
âgées qui vivent est en ch et celle dés
qu'on n'ait pas été capable de faire
mieux ou plus vite ça j'avoue je trouve
ça du sel le contraste entre la gestion
populationnelle de la cabine et la
gestion un essai chez cndd et le contrat
c'est beaucoup trop marqué et c'est ça
qui viennent chercher
[Musique]
le drame c'est le nombre de morts mais
aussi et peut-être surtout les
conditions dans lesquelles les années
sont décédés nous est arrivé de
ne pas avoir dans face à sète personnel
juste pour pouvoir tourner les patients
en effet rangé les hydrater
qu'est ce que vous avez vu qui vous a le
plus choqué chez les patients auprès des
résidents ont rentré des chambres on les
retrouve et tellement souffrent seul aux
6 votre famille j'avais même pib s'était
qui la personne qui en faisait tellement
de deux pénalités hors de moi de leurs
derniers moments de vie ce sont des
numéros parce que je les appelle par
leur numéro de chambre
le manque de soin a eu un impact sur le
taux de mortalité en ch et celle des en
moyenne en nouvelle écosse en ontario
alberta et colombie britannique
26 % des résidents qui ont attrapé la
coved sont morts au québec c'est 42% qui
est responsable de ça hein ça doit être
moi je suis ministre responsable des
aînés
est-ce que ça se peut que vous n'ayez
pas suffisamment pouvoir le pouvoir dans
lévis madame marois c'est extrêmement
relatif le pouvoir c'est celui que le
premier ministre donne le premier mené
ce que le pouvoir
c'est lui qui décide des orientations ou
le premier ministre françois legault a
refusé de nous accorder une entrevue
pour défendre son bilan mais à plusieurs
reprises pendant la crise
il a reconnu l'échec dans les ch et
celle des fosses des habilités on a
connu une défaite dans nos centres de
soins de longue durée
il a fait porter le poids de cette
défaite sur les négligences du passé
notre société nos gouvernements j'inclus
mieux on peut porter assez d'attention
au cours des dernières années à nos
centres de soins de longue durée mais
jamais à notre connaissance il n'a
reconnu que son gouvernement aurait pu
faire mieux pendant la pandémie
pour limiter les décès et la souffrance
des aînés
[Musique]
e